JENNA: And I am
personally super thrilled
to have today Amanda Haas,
who is not only a cookbook
author, but a Director of
Culinary for Williams-Sonoma.
And the specific book we're
going to talk about today is
the "Anti-Inflammation
Cookbook,"
which I think connects very
deeply with our mission
to really show you how food
connects to how you can feel,
and how you could
be your best self.
So please join me
in welcoming Amanda.
AMANDA HAAS: Thank
you, everyone.
Hi, thank you, Jenna.
I'm so excited to be here today.
And I think it's
interesting as she
was sharing your
mission with me,
we are very well
aligned in that.
JENNA: Very much so, yes.
AMANDA HAAS: Yeah,
so hello everyone.
What a beautiful space to be in.
As I was preparing
this week and thinking
about who my audience
was, I was really
thinking about how your work
affects my life every day.
Like I wake up really
early every morning.
And one of the first things
I do while I make my coffee
is go to Google
News, and read what's
been perfectly curated
for me every morning,
and get my taste of the world.
And then get on with my day,
and do something like come here,
and it's Google Maps.
And then I get to
work, or I come here,
and I'm with my family,
and what do I do all day?
I Google things.
And so you have made my life so
much easier through your work.
And it's so meaningful.
So it's a real
pleasure for me to get
to share my passion
and my work with you
all today, even for this
short amount of time.
So two of the things that I'm
the most passionate about.
One is teaching
people how to cook.
So I don't know how
many of you spend
a lot of time in the kitchen.
But I love instructing
and teaching people
how to cook every day.
And then the other
thing I love is
this conversation between
what we eat and how we feel.
And as it pertains
to inflammation.
So that's going to be a
part of the conversation
that we'll just weave into
the cooking piece today.
So thank you for spending
this time with me.
I know that there
are many other things
you could be doing today.
So start off with a
question, how many of you
have seen the movie
"Ratatouille?"
Oh.
Almost everybody,
I'm not the only one.
I think it's my
favorite Pixar movie.
We'll see if "Finding
Dory" beats it this summer.
But the thing I love about that
movie, if you haven't seen it,
is that there's
this great theme.
And Remi, the rat, who's
so inspired to cook,
and doesn't care
that he's a rat,
worships Chef Gusteau, right?
And Chef Gusteau, the Parisian
chef who'd won all the awards,
and is a great cook, and
has his Michelin stars,
his motto was anyone can cook.
And when I saw
that movie it just
really resonated with me because
I do think anyone can cook.
But as an instructor
and a cookbook author,
I think a lot of
the responsibility
is on me to teach you how to do
that and how to write recipes.
Or talk to you in
a way that makes
it so easy you want
to go home and try
to recreate these things today.
So whether you are nine or
you're 60, it doesn't matter.
Hopefully when you
leave here today
you'll want to
take these recipes
and make them for
yourselves at home.
The other part of this
conversation that we'll have
is, why should we even care
about inflammation or food,
and how it makes us feel?
And for me, it's a
really personal journey,
like it is for everyone.
And food is such
a personal thing.
But basically over
the last 20 years
I've been suffering
from some health things
that no one could
really explain.
We joke that I kind
of look normal,
but I didn't feel normal.
[LAUGHTER]
So you know, allergies,
and asthma, and eczema,
and then I started getting
chronic heartburn as I aged.
And then got signs of
rheumatoid arthritis
that we couldn't explain.
So all of these problems, and
back problems my whole life.
And it was so interesting
because I tried everything.
I tried all kinds
of regular medicine.
I tried East meets
West-- acupuncture,
acupressure, physical therapy.
And about seven years ago I
walked into an allergist's
office, and I started
listing my ailments,
and I was crying because
about once a year I
would just be so upset
about this, wondering
why can't I get better?
And he stopped me, and
he said, Amanda, there's
some really good news here.
Everything that you're
talking about is inflammation.
It's just a different form
of inflammation in your body.
And all that meant was
that your body is reacting
to some outside irritant.
So he said, guess what?
You're a cook.
You can fix this.
I know that there's
something that you're
eating that is making
you feel terrible.
And it's showing itself in all
of these ridiculous things that
are going on with you.
So he sent me away.
And he also said, and
once you figure it out,
you've got to do
something about it.
You've got to like shout
it from the rooftops,
if you can fix this.
So he told me, quit gluten.
I don't want you having a
bite of gluten for two weeks,
and tell me what happens.
And fortunately
or unfortunately,
the changes were so
profound within two days,
I couldn't even believe it.
And so I was almost
angry at myself
that that's the last
thing that I'd turned to.
That I used food as my last
solution, instead of the first.
And so what happened is
it became super empowering
to know that what I was eating
could make me feel great,
or it could make me feel
terrible really quickly.
And that every choice I make
when I sit down at the table
affects my well-being.
So this book is a
culmination of that journey.
And hopefully it
pertains to a lot of us
because it's not just
about what I can't have,
or what I can have, it's
more about explaining
what's gone on with food,
and why so many of us
are reacting to
different types of food
now that we didn't used
to have problems with.
And the whole idea
that, let's explain it
with this great doctor who has
spoken to Google before Dr.
Bradley Jacobs.
He talks about the ingredients,
and why a lot of us
are struggling.
And then I say, let's just
throw those out the window,
and let's cook with ingredients
that make us feel really great.
So Gusteau said anyone can cook.
I think if I had
a motto mine would
be, I want people
to say about me,
her food tastes
so good you don't
care that it's good for you.
It's just delicious,
and comforting,
and all of those
things, and it just
happens to be really,
really good for you.
So today we're going to cook
two of my favorite recipes
from the book.
JENNA: Excellent
AMANDA HAAS: And I'm
going to use Jenna to help
get me going on all of this.
And I am not a vegetarian.
Are there any vegetarians here?
One, two, OK, a couple, three.
Yeah, so as I've kind
of been on this road
to wellness I definitely
realized I was
eating too much animal protein.
And I've been taking
a greater interest
in understanding
where it comes from,
and what animal protein
I'm choosing to eat.
So that being said, I wanted
to develop some recipes that
are much more approachable and
delicious that are vegetarian
for my family to eat all week.
And that are really
simple to make.
So I cheated in the spirit
of television, right.
You can just speed things up
a little bit for us today.
JENNA: Google Vision.
AMANDA HAAS: Google
Vision, we'll call it,
right, I love that.
This is a red lentil curry
that I'm going to make.
And all I did to start was
start sauteing some onions.
So many cultures
and so many recipes
start with something like,
put some oil in the pan,
put it over medium heat,
saute for eight to 10 minutes
the onions until they're
soft and translucent.
I like to remind people that we
want to look for visual cues,
right?
I can write it and say, cook
them for six to eight minutes.
But everybody cooks differently,
temperatures are different.
And so you can see
here I let them get
pretty brown and caramelized.
The sugars have
released, and that's
why they'll be brown,
and soft, and delicious.
If you were just to
throw all of this liquid
in without doing that, you
wouldn't soften the onions,
and you would never get
any of that sweetness.
So we want that, the fancy
term, the maillard reaction,
of the onions to
cook and the sugars
to be released to
come out because it's
going to add so much flavor
to what we're making.
So you're going to see this
in a million types of recipes
from all around the globe.
And it's a really nice
way to start things.
So my onions went for
probably six to eight minutes.
And now I'm going
to add some garlic.
This just goes for about
a minute because garlic
burns really quickly.
And if it burns you're going to
get that really bitter taste.
And it's going to spread
throughout the curry, which
we don't want.
We want it to still be
delicious and sweet.
So I'm going to add that.
Garlic and onions are both
from the allium family,
which have amazing
anti-inflammatory properties
on their own and help
with digestion too.
I've got fresh ginger.
And we talk a lot in the
book about ingredients
and the positive
benefits of them.
What's interesting
in Asia, and as I
try to educate myself
more on Asian cuisines,
everywhere from Thailand,
which this kind of comes from,
to India, they've all been
using spices and herbs that are
really good for us for ages.
And so I had to get
away from pulling
from a lot of the Mediterranean
recipes I'm familiar with.
And try to pull in the rest
of the world in my cooking.
JENNA: Yeah, I think global
spice perspective is really
important, especially
in bringing flavor
to things like vegetables
without a ton of salt,
or sugars, or oils.
Like you can really build a
lot of foundational flavor
just through spices.
AMANDA HAAS: Yeah,
it's incredible.
And I think that
a lot of times I
use salt generously when I cook.
But the thing is when
you're cooking at home,
you'll never use as much
salt as in a restaurant,
which is great.
JENNA: You really don't
want to know generally
restaurant recipes.
AMANDA HAAS: You don't.
And so I don't worry about
how much not salt I add.
JENNA: Not here.
AMANDA HAAS: Right, yeah.
But not here.
Never.
JENNA: Never, never, never.
AMANDA HAAS: But the thing is,
spices give you so much flavor
that you'll probably
find yourself
cooking with less salt, if
you're using a lot of spices.
JENNA: Absolutely agree.
AMANDA HAAS: So I just put
in a blend of Garam Masala,
and they can vary
a little bit what's
in it-- coriander, cumin,
I can't name all of them
off the bat.
But it's like a really
nice warm blend of spices.
And it's just going to
add a ton of flavor.
And then I added
this red chili paste,
which it doesn't want
to move around the pan.
But that's OK.
It's going to dissolve
a little bit when
I add my other ingredients.
I'm going to turn up the heat on
this amazing induction cooktop
that you have.
All I'm looking for here is
to cook this a little bit.
So if you can see in this
pot, the red chili paste
is going to turn a little
bit more brick in color.
It's going to turn a
little more orange.
And that's just bringing
out the flavors in it,
again, before we add
those other things.
Is there an oil I
prefer to cook with?
So I talk about different
oils in the book.
I love olive oil for a
lot of the things I do.
I'm using canola oil in this,
which has some great health
benefits as well.
It's a really
neutral tasting oil.
So if I don't want the oil to
be the strong flavor in it,
I'll usually cook with canola.
And the one thing that
I look for in oils, I do
look for organic and non-GMO
because so many of those things
can be sprayed so
heavily with pesticides.
Canola is one of those.
So there are some great
ones on the market
now that you can find
at your local store that
say non-GMO and organic for a
fairly inexpensive price, which
is great.
So can you see how that
all just looks dark.
And look at all that stuff
on the bottom of the pan, all
that brown stuff.
It's what I like to
call yummy goodness.
JENNA: Yum yums, I think
is the technical term.
AMANDA HAAS: It is.
I'm pretty sure it is.
JENNA: The yum
yums at the bottom
AMANDA HAAS: And
so basically that's
all of that
caramelized goodness.
And you don't want
to get rid of it.
You want to be able to bring it
into the flavors of what you're
making.
The fancy term of what I
just did, we're deglazing.
And so see how I can
lift off all of that.
I put some cold
liquid in the pan,
and it's going to react with
the food on the bottom of it,
and just lift it right up.
So I just put in a little
of my liquid to start.
And all of that is going to
become part of this foundation
for this curry,
which is delicious.
So whether you're doing a
vegetarian dish like this,
or you're doing something that's
meat-based, like a protein,
you know steak, beef
caramelizes really
well like that, you want all of
that back up into your sauce.
We would never want
to throw it away
unless you happen
to really burn it.
You would have to start fresh.
But now that it's in I'm going
to crank this up a little bit,
and add the rest of my liquids.
OK, great.
So I'm going to
bring it up to high
just to bring it to a simmer.
Water is a very
underutilized ingredient
I think when you cook.
And it's kind of like were
just talking about oils.
When you want something neutral,
but you need the liquid,
don't forget about it right.
You could certainly do
chicken stock or vegetable
stock, if you wanted.
But you're adding another
flavor component there.
So I'll use water
when I don't have
stock for things like risotto.
You can totally use it to
interchange with things.
And I just don't
want stock competing
with these other flavors that
I've got going on in the pot.
JENNA: Interesting.
AMANDA HAAS: Yeah.
So now what we're going to do is
just add a couple more liquids.
And this is so easy
in that you're just
putting a bunch of
things in at once,
and then we're going
to let it simmer.
We're going to add
the other components.
Coconut milk.
You guys can read
in the book as well,
coconut oil got a really
bad rap for a long time
because we were refining it.
But it is we're finding
basically that great rule
of thumb that if it
comes from nature,
it's probably good for you.
JENNA: Yeah, if
you leave it alone.
AMANDA HAAS: Right,
if you leave it alone.
And so coconut oil is
having a total comeback.
JENNA: Oh yeah,
so hot right now.
AMANDA HAAS: It's
It really is.
Coconut milk, I
love cooking with.
And again, it's giving you
that awesome depth of flavor,
and some fat to add
flavor when you're
cooking vegetarian things.
Fat is flavor, as we like to
say in the culinary world.
And so I think a lot of people
when they love to crave steak,
and crave chicken
with skin, and things
like that, it's the fat that
we love in our diet, which
can be really good for us.
But I love to look for
things that can replace them.
I'm going to add some lime
juice too for the acid,
so it balances the
richness of the coconut.
And then, Jenna, I wasn't
talking to you about this.
Who was I talking to?
Oh, with Chef.
I was talking to
Chef Didi about this
at the beginning, how agave
syrup is already a hot thing.
We're already starting to
see in the food community
that we're probably not
that crazy about it anymore.
And that the best natural
sweeteners are honey and maple
syrup, as you find
them in nature.
And so it's interesting
because they think now
agave syrup can spike
your blood sugar
in ways that were
not crazy about.
JENNA: That's so interesting.
AMANDA HAAS: Right?
Because it's got
more fructose in it.
JENNA: Yeah, but that
was kind of counter
indicated a couple years ago.
AMANDA HAAS: Exactly.
JENNA: You always
have to pay attention.
The food world
evolves so quickly.
AMANDA HAAS: It
does, and I think
you can't chase every trend.
But I think, again, it comes
back to some common sense.
And what I loved about having
a doctor partner with me
on the book is that he could
kind of prove my hypotheses.
And he was saying,
you know stick
to things that are natural, and
just don't use a ton of them.
So agave I was using.
But I've switched
to honey at home,
and I put maple
syrup when I need to.
I put maple syrup in my coffee.
I don't know why I
think that's tasty.
But I love it.
JENNA: That's delicious.
AMANDA HAAS: Yeah,
so we're going
to do a little agave for sweet.
And just bring this up
to a simmer before I add
the lentils.
And then we're going to
let those cook for about 10
or 15 minutes on their own.
And then just put in some
vegetables to finish it off.
And that's the dish.
So it's pretty straightforward.
The one thing to keep in mind
as you're making something
like this is that you can
totally make it your own.
So a lot of times we'll
do chicken in this.
If I have a chicken or I roast
a chicken, I'll add part of that
into this dish.
You could do tofu,
if you are vegetarian
and you want another
source of protein.
You can switch up your veggies
to whatever's seasonal.
JENNA: Sure.
AMANDA HAAS: If you
want more color,
I'll put broccoli in it
instead of cauliflower.
JENNA: Bell pepper even, maybe.
AMANDA HAAS: Bell pepper
would be delicious.
And I would probably
cook those off
with the onion at the beginning
just to kind of caramelize
and sweeten those
up a little bit.
So far so good?
JENNA: Curry can be
a good kitchen clean.
Like, oh what do I have
in the veggie basket?
AMANDA HAAS: I totally
agree with you.
And that's normally how I do it.
I was laughing when I saw
this recipe because I'm
like, when's the
last time I actually
cooked the recipe like this?
I was like it's
normally I always
have something green
in my refrigerator.
Or the other thing I love
to do is roast vegetables
off at a really high
heat because, again, they
get caramelized and sweet.
So if you think people
don't like cauliflower,
I don't know if you like
cauliflower over here,
roasted it's a lot sweeter.
So you can always
roast off vegetables,
and then put them in here
at the last minute too.
And it gives a different
element of flavor.
So you can see that
everything's simmering now,
which is right what I want.
Got my water.
Do we have a lid
for this big pot?
We'll get one.
Thank you, Chef.
And all I'm going to do is
turn it down with the lid on.
And let it simmer,
which means I just
want a little bit of a bubble
going when the lid's on.
If steam is coming
out of it like crazy,
you'll know that
we are cooking it
at too high of a temperature.
So can someone be my
volunteer to watch
the clock for about
10 minutes, 10 or 15,
and let me when time's up?
Thank you.
Thank you, lovely
assistant over there.
JENNA: Thank you.
AMANDA HAAS: So let's
put a lid on it.
And then we'll move
on to another recipe
while we're waiting
for this one to finish.
I think three will be good.
OK, great.
So this literally when
it's done cooking there,
we're just going to
add our vegetables in.
And then I'm going
to teach you how
to season it, and taste for
flavorings at the end of it.
But great recipe to take home,
and make your own, and really
just practice kind of
the foundation of it,
and going from there.
JENNA: And what would you
generally serve that with?
AMANDA HAAS: So I like to
serve it kind of as the entree.
And today you will try
it with some brown rice.
So it's really nice if you
want to do it like that.
This would be a really typical
weeknight meal in my house
because you could make it ahead.
And actually the flavors
develop even more, which I love.
So with some rice,
or even quinoa
if you wanted on the
side would be great.
It'd be really great.
We're just going to do
a little change here.
And then let's talk
about our quinoa
while we get ready to
do the whole salad.
Who here likes quinoa?
Yeah.
It's been a total change.
No, shaking your head.
You're in the same camp
I was for a long time.
So when the lovely
doctor told me
I couldn't have gluten
anymore, my first thought
was I was going to
get fired from my job
because we create
products all day long
that are full of gluten.
You know like amazing baked
goods, and cookies, and bread.
So that was my first fear.
And then my second
was that I was
going to have to learn how to
like quinoa because it really
never did it for me.
I love couscous.
I love all those great
grain salads you could get.
But a couple of tricks,
which I learned,
which are so much better.
And Jenna, do you
mind handing me
that chinois, that big sieve
that's down on the end?
Thank you so much.
One is that quinoa naturally
has a natural pesticide
on it called saponins.
And when you rinse the
quinoa, you rinse that off.
So if any of you ever
had it, and you're like,
there's this taste about
it that you just don't like
or I can't identify,
it's probably
the saponins on the quinoa.
JENNA: Fascinating.
AMANDA HAAS: Weird, right?
JENNA: Yeah, I never heard that.
AMANDA HAAS: Right, so it's
like to rinse or not to rinse?
Now, to rinse is what I say.
So you rinse those off.
And then it's a really
easy formula for cooking.
And it's just like rice.
So I love formulas
when I'm cooking,
just so that you do it
once, and you remember.
JENNA: I think you're
speaking to the right crowd
in that regard.
AMANDA HAAS: Am I?
I love it.
I love having a foundation, and
then you can make it your own.
But with quinoa, like rice,
all you're going to do
is two parts water
to one part quinoa.
It's that simple.
And a little bit of
salt. Again, if you
wanted to put it in a stock you
could if you want more flavor
in that.
I usually just do it with water,
and then a little bit of salt,
and you're good to go.
So I'm just going to put
this right in the pot.
And then I'm going
to eyeball my water.
You know what I
love about cooking,
and this is why I'm not a great
baker, because it doesn't have
to be that exact all the time.
It's OK to eyeball things,
or change out ingredients
when you have something else.
So you start with
that foundation,
and then you get to
make it your own.
Put this over here.
Jenna, I'm going to have you
watch some of this stuff.
No actually, I'm going to put
you to work on the vinaigrette
as well.
I forgot--
JENNA: I don't know.
AMANDA HAAS: --I have
another job for you.
So this is literally how
we're going to do this, folks.
Two parts water.
JENNA: Very technical.
AMANDA HAAS: Very,
very technical, right?
Pinch of salt. I always keep
salt and pepper at the cooktop.
You know they're going to
be your best friends when
you cook.
And another thing to remember
is that you taste all the time
as a cook.
You know if you wait until the
end sometimes it's too late.
So you want to be
tasting as you go.
And you'll watch me
taste the lentils
before I add the
veggies back in just
to kind of see where
we are on the flavors.
I'm pretty sure it's
going to need salt.
And I'll do the same
thing as I cook and make
these other things for you.
So always make
sure you're tasting
and adjusting as you go.
Now let's see if I can
use this fancy cooktop.
I can.
JENNA: So how long
for quinoa, generally?
AMANDA HAAS: So quinoa is
really easy in that it's
about 15 to 20 minutes.
Can you guys see
actually on my spoon
how are these tiny, cute,
little grains right?
They're actually seeds.
It's going to split.
And it's going to give
this cute little white seam
on the outside of it.
So all we're looking
for it to do is split.
And you can overcook it just
like you'd overcook anything.
It's certainly not
the end of the world.
But I'm probably going to
check it at about 12 minutes.
And then let it
go as long as 20.
So we'll see how
hot this cooktop is,
and give it a whirl.
I'm going to let that come to a
boil before I put a lid on it.
JENNA: All right,
what's the plan?
AMANDA HAAS: So the
next plan, what we'll do
is we'll make the
vinaigrette for the quinoa
while we're waiting for
these other things to cook.
How many of you have
made vinaigrettes before?
Yeah, OK, fantastic.
One of the things
that I love, Jenna,
is that if you go and you buy
salad dressing or vinaigrette
at the store, it's one
of those things that
can be loaded with
sodium and salt.
And you don't need the
extra fillers in them.
They're so easy to make at home.
When people ask me
what's one of the best
things you could do
for yourself at home,
I say make vinaigrettes.
And you can do a big batch.
I love to just make
a huge thing of it.
And again, it's about
proportions and ratios.
So we're going to learn that.
And then you just
keep them around.
Oh, I love how everything
is made for us here.
It's amazing.
Do you want to bring
this up here for you?
JENNA: Sure.
AMANDA HAAS: And then I'm
going to grab the garlic.
And then we're going to just do
one really basic vinaigrette.
People always ask
me, especially where
I work at Williams-Sonoma, we
sell the most amazing tools
ever, they're like
what do you really
have to have in your kitchen?
Like a knife, a great knife A
great knife and a great cutting
board.
I love both things.
So I'm going to show you a
little trick today with one
of my favorite knives.
And first, I'm going to just
push down on that garlic.
See how I do that?
Because I want to mince it, and
I want to get it really fine.
But this salt is going
to act as an abrasive.
So when you go to
chop it it's just
going to kind of like
bring it together.
It's really, really easy.
And then I'm going to
have you finish off
the vinaigrette for us.
JENNA: For sure,
that's a fun trick.
I didn't know that one.
AMANDA HAAS: It's kind of
like a little chef hack.
You look really
serious and fancy,
and it's not that hard to do.
Can I get a second timer for my
quinoa please for 12 minutes?
Thank you.
All right so I just sprinkled
a little bit of kosher salt.
Kosher salt's got a
larger grain to it.
And I put that on the garlic.
And now watch what
I'm going to do.
I'm just going to
start chopping.
You can hold it.
You guys see how I'm
holding the knife?
Just got my thumb and my index
finger around it like this.
It creates stability.
And what you'll see is
that all I'm going to do
is rock my wrist.
I'm not going to be taking
the knife up like this.
You can usually just keep the
tip of your knife on the board.
And you let your
wrist do the work.
So I'm just going to
start to chop this.
But it would be a lot
more slippery if I
didn't have the salt on it.
And then what you can do is
kind of press all this together.
And this is going to help
me form like really finally
chopped pieces of garlic.
JENNA: Fascinating.
AMANDA HAAS: So if
you do a ton of it
at once it's actually easier
if you have a bunch of cloves
because you've got more surface
area kind of to work with.
But I just kind of press it.
It's kind of fun, right?
You look really
grown up and serious.
Morgan over there has
got this mastered.
So great.
Just keep bringing it back
together and chopping away.
I just don't want really
huge chunks of it.
So when you're eating the
salad, you're like, whoa,
I just got so much garlic.
Again, it's so great for
just digestion garlic is.
And so I try to use
it whenever I can.
And in vinaigrettes it adds
a great layer of flavor.
OK, so I'm putting
this in as my base
because this is one
of my favorites.
Who's ready to talk formula?
JENNA: What you got?
AMANDA HAAS: OK, really easy.
The opinions have
changed on this,
but I like to use two parts
oil to one part acid when
you're making a vinaigrette.
And then usually if you
don't want to be broken
you can use a binder.
JENNA: OK.
AMANDA HAAS: So You can use as
much of a binder as you want.
Some of the ones we
love to use, mustard,
so like a Dijon mustard, it'll
bring it all together for you,
mayonnaise I love mayonnaise
a little too much.
You could use egg yolk, you
know that's a classic one.
People also in very old styles
of cooking use blood, not a fan
personally.
Haven't done that
since culinary school,
and I probably will never again.
JENNA: Maybe not.
AMANDA HAAS: Yeah,
no, I'll pass on that.
Thank you very much.
Not my thing.
So I'm starting with garlic.
And you could add any
aromatic that you want.
You could add fresh
herbs if you want.
You can add something
for sweetness.
But now all I want
to do is I want
to start by adding my binder.
So Jenna, if you want
to put the Dijon in.
Do you need a little spoon?
There you go.
And then we have
a whisk for you.
Perfect.
I start with a
pinch of salt, guys.
And then now I want
you to take your acid.
So today we're
using lemon juice.
This is kind of my version of
like a healthy Caesar dressing,
if you wanted to do.
And I just want you
to whisk that in.
If you wanted you
could use orange juice,
lime juice, balsamic vinegar.
You know there are so many.
I use a lot of sherry vinegar.
So completely depends
on your taste.
When I'm making
salads that I want
to taste really fresh and clean,
I usually go toward citrus.
I just love the flavor of strong
citrus in my vinaigrettes.
JENNA: All right.
AMANDA HAAS: So look
at how easy that is?
See, already figured out.
So that was your one part acid.
And now you need two parts oil.
JENNA: All right, what
kind of oil are we using?
AMANDA HAAS: We're
going to use olive oil.
And we're just going
to eyeball this again,
crazy people that we are.
JENNA: Getting crazy in here.
AMANDA HAAS: Yeah, so you can
add a little bit to start,
and whisk it in.
And you'll see it
start to come together.
One of the coolest
things about this
too is if you whisk too quickly,
and you're not emulsifying
as you go, doesn't matter.
Just put it in a jar, and
shake it as hard as you can.
And it'll bring
it back together.
You've clearly done
this once or twice.
JENNA: I don't know
what you're talking.
AMANDA HAAS: Yeah, she's
like, no, I don't know.
I just do it every day.
JENNA: First time.
AMANDA HAAS: But so
far, so good right?
Not too hard to do.
But it can totally change
the way your food tastes.
And it's a really easy
thing to do at home.
My younger son thinks
he's super cool because he
can make a vinaigrette right?
And it sounds super fancy.
JENNA: Pretty
cool, I don't know.
AMANDA HAAS: Yeah.
But it's nice to have around.
Then when you come
home from work,
it's so much easier
to make a salad.
JENNA: You, make
the vinaigrette.
You wash the greens.
AMANDA HAAS: Yes.
JENNA: You, chop the veggies.
AMANDA HAAS: Exactly.
JENNA: I like it.
You'll just see all kinds of
Mason jars in my refrigerator.
It looks like a little
scientist's workshop, right.
There's balsamic, there's
a citrus one usually.
I like to do one if I'm
making Mexican food where--
Oh, thank you.
I've got my queue
to check my lentils.
--I'll do some with like
a chipotle and adobo,
and use that as the base.
And then add honey and
orange juice and oil.
One of my favorites, or lime
juice should be good too.
Check it out.
This looks good.
I'm going to taste, like
I promised you I would.
Let's see.
It's tasty, but it needs
more salt, for sure.
Oh let's add the veggies now.
Let's be wild.
Not too much is
going to go wrong.
That's the other thing about
cooking when people are like,
what if I mess it up?
Guess what, who cares?
It's so cool to be cooking.
And people love when you
cook for them, right.
And so sometimes we mess up.
My family has to eat
all of my mistakes.
There are a lot of them.
JENNA: That's good
lessons always too.
Then what you did wrong,
you don't do it again.
AMANDA HAAS: Absolutely.
You know especially cooking
my way through this book,
where I had to use
different ingredients than I
was used to or more of
things than I was used to,
I messed up a ton.
But it's kind of fun.
It's part of the journey.
JENNA: How long did it
take you to write the book?
AMANDA HAAS: Oh my.
It took me a long time to write
the proposal because I couldn't
figure out how to
present a topic that was
so serious to people, right.
JENNA: It's not a serious book
though, it's very accessible.
AMANDA HAAS: So I wanted to kind
of tell that personal story,
and make people feel
like they could relate.
So it took me probably four
months to write the proposal.
And keep in mind I was doing it
on nights and weekends, right,
outside of my regular job.
And then probably
a solid six months
on the weekends cooking to
develop all the recipes.
I'd try to do like
five or six a weekend,
and then just
throw parties where
you invite your
whole block over,
and be like, what do you think?
Critique me.
Which everybody did by the way.
But it worked out.
So it's good.
I added the cauliflower
and the garnet yam.
I'm going to give it another
10 minutes for my lovely timing
team.
And let's see how
this is doing in here.
Oh, we'll turn up a little bit.
Every cooktop's
different, right.
So if I tell you to cook
on low or medium low, again
that visual cue, you just
want to be barely bubbling
while it's simmering, and it
wasn't doing that quite yet.
So we'll check on that.
JENNA: Right, how
do we know we're
done with the vinaigrette?
AMANDA HAAS: So again,
we're going to taste.
I want a little pepper in mine.
I know that Jenna.
Let's put that in.
And, of course, you can add, if
you like things really peppery,
use a ton more.
One interesting
thing about pepper
is that, you'll read
about in the book as well,
it's a thermogenic.
And so when you combine
it with other spices,
it releases the bioavailability
of that spice more,
which is a crazy term
for saying it makes it
absorb into your body better.
So tumeric, you hear a lot about
with anti-inflammatory cooking.
It's an amazing ingredient.
You'll usually see
it with black pepper
because black pepper
makes it I think
2,000% more available to
be absorbed into your body.
JENNA: Wow.
AMANDA HAAS: So black
pepper's amazing.
How does it taste?
JENNA: Delicious, FYI.
AMANDA HAAS: Is it?
Oh, good, see you're pro.
Next time, you want to go
crazy, do lime juice, right.
JENNA: That would be good.
AMANDA HAAS: I like it.
JENNA: Yeah.
AMANDA HAAS: And going
into something like quinoa,
you want it to be
a little bit more
pungent because
quinoa is so neutral,
it can kind of taste flat.
JENNA: Give it a punch.
AMANDA HAAS: Yeah, like on
lettuce I like it like this.
And when you get
it in the quinoa,
we might want a
little bit more acid
to give it a little
more flavor, OK.
So our vinaigrette is done.
And now we can start working
on the other components
of the quinoa salad.
JENNA: All right.
AMANDA HAAS: With the
magic of Google Vision
it just all slides
into the picture here.
We do it all.
AMANDA HAAS: I'm
going to teach you
guys a couple of knife skills
and what did you call them?
Google hacks.
JENNA: Hacks.
AMANDA HAAS: Hacks.
We're going to do some kitchen
hacks for you right now
to make it easier
to make this salad.
Any questions as we're going?
We're good?
Yeah?
Yeah, so a lot of people do
use egg yolks as a binder, raw.
And so if you don't want
to be eating raw egg yolk,
you definitely steer
clear of that one.
Yeah, I love the flavor.
But a lot of people
are nervous about that.
Rightfully so.
OK, so we have all of these
beautiful things all ready
that we're going to put
into our salad today.
And I'm just going to teach
you how to do these yourself
a couple other ways.
So people always say to
me, what's your best tool?
And I joke, it's called a knife.
But really, like everything
here you could do with a knife.
And then there are a couple
other little tools I like.
So I wonder too, I don't
know if you guys have
any more green onions back
there hiding in the kitchen.
But I'll show you one
more trick, if you do.
That'd be great.
Thank you.
But first with the carrots,
let me show you something
that's just a fun trick.
You guys this space
is so amazing.
I don't know who had to do this.
But look at how
gorgeous this is.
My carrots aren't going to
look this beautiful and this
perfect, pretty amazing.
So I'm just going
to peel my carrot.
This is my favorite
peeler, by the way.
This is what I use
all day, every day.
I like to do things as simply
as possible for recipes.
But the thing is we
eat with our eyes.
We want things to
look beautiful.
And so any time I can
do a little short cut
and make it really
pretty, I like to do that.
And for some reason
most of us think
things are really pretty
when they're on the bias,
you know when they're cut on an
angle, instead of straight on.
It's funny.
JENNA: Well, it's
fancy that way.
AMANDA HAAS: Right,
then so you can do this,
which is slightly on the bias.
Or you can cut them, even
with this I'll show you.
So for green onions, otherwise
known as scallions, all I do
is cut the tops off.
And then you just want to
put your knife at an angle.
And I'm just going to
start slicing across them.
I don't know why,
doesn't that look nice?
It's like fancy, super fancy.
It just elevates the
look of the recipe.
So we're going to do that.
See again, I'm just using my
fingers to stabilize the knife,
and keeping the tip of
the knife on the board.
And then the oh-so-imporant
claw on the other side.
When you keep your fingers
wrapped underneath you
don't have to worry
about cutting them off.
So an important
little tip for us.
Watch, I'm just
going to go straight
into the quinoa with this.
In you go.
And then I'll add the pine nuts
that's there in front of me.
Pine nuts are really
expensive right now.
They're hard to come by.
And so I love them for flavor.
I love them in my pesto.
But another alternative
would be roasted almonds
would be delicious.
Or you can buy slivered
almonds, and just toast them
in a pan really quickly.
I also love pistachios
in salads or cashews.
So I teach you how to toast them
on a sheet pan, where you just
put them in an oven for
a couple of minutes.
That's the less finicky
way to do it because they
won't burn so quickly.
But if you're watching
them and you pay attention,
you can do them on the cooktop.
And just toast them
really quickly.
And make sure they don't burn,
and get them off the heat.
JENNA: Don't get distracted.
AMANDA HAAS: Don't
get distracted, right?
JENNA: Every time I do it,
I inevitably burn some.
AMANDA HAAS: Right.
JENNA: Oh, what did you say?
Burnt.
AMANDA HAAS: Burnt in
that amount of time.
JENNA: Literally.
AMANDA HAAS: You're
totally not kidding.
How do I store mine?
I store my nuts in
the freezer, actually.
I think it extends the
life of them a little bit.
So well-sealed in the freezer.
Yeah, unless I'm going to
use them really quickly.
AUDIENCE: But I never do.
AMANDA HAAS: Right.
Yeah, so keep them stored
tightly in the freezer.
Currants, I love
balances in salads
where you've got a little bit
of every flavor component going
on.
So something sweet,
currants are great.
They're small, so they're
easy to mix through things.
If you want them really plump
and juicy in your salad,
you can rehydrate them by
just putting them in a couple
tablespoons of hot water.
So while I make this I would
let them sit in the hot water.
And they just get a little
plumper and juicier for you.
Another one would be,
I love dried cherries,
dried blueberries are delicious,
cranberries of course.
Again, this is one
of those things where
I'm a stickler about organics.
Thank you for the quinoa cue.
Because they're such
small, soft fruits
that they can absorb all
those pesticides so quickly.
So I think it's worth
paying a little bit extra
for the organic.
So can you guys see
my quinoa right here?
Can you see how it's split?
So you're going to see this
little white seam popping out.
And as always I'm
going to taste,
and see where we are on it.
It's like pasta.
You want it to have a little
bit of a bite, but not too much.
So I'm going to let it go
for about two more minutes.
You can see the liquid
in there too, Jenna.
JENNA: And do you expect
that it will absorb it all?
AMANDA HAAS: If it's a
perfect day and the humidity
is right in the world, and
everything's great, yes.
If not, I would just
put it right back
through that chinois.
JENNA: Chinois, yup.
AMANDA HAAS: And just
skim off the water.
And then another
great little trick
for cooling it down quickly,
you could let it sit in the pot
and turn off the heat.
I'll put mine onto a big baking
sheet and just spread it out,
and it cools down in
a matter of minutes.
And then you're ready to go
and put it into your salad.
So let's do one more
little trick here
with the largest carrot I think
I've ever seen in my life.
JENNA: It's a pretty
healthy carrot.
AMANDA HAAS: That is
a big carrot, right?
You could certainly save
the scraps, you guys,
for anything like
a veggie stock too.
So I love it when I can cook
and save things like that.
So this is a super fancy
thing we're going to do.
I'm going to teach you
two things-- julienning
versus dicing.
But julienning, my friend,
Melissa, taught me this,
you're going to slice the
carrot at a bias, again.
These big fancy pieces,
and then look at this.
I don't know why I think this
is the coolest trick I've ever
seen.
I'll get this out of
the way while we do it.
Literally, I don't
think I learned this
until about two years ago.
And I thought she was so
smart for teaching me this.
And I always make her teach
other people the same thing.
So you can line them up, and
then you just cut across,
and you hold them down.
So if you stack them
on top of each other,
that one is a little
too thick, you
can just move really quickly.
So you could certainly do one
thing with a piece at a time.
But if you stack them
over each other like that
and overlap them a little
bit, you'll go faster.
So that's just a
really pretty way
to make something look a little
bit nicer for your salad.
They did that for the cover of
the books, so I'm like forever
I'll be julienning.
But I just tell people
to dice it, you know.
So show you a dice too.
One really important thing
when you're working with knives
is that you want to be
working with flat surfaces.
You know it's scary to have
something rolling around
on a cutting board for
you when you're working
with something this sharp.
And so I like to
cut something off
like a sweet potato,
a potato, carrots,
I always like to give myself a
steady base when I'm slicing.
So then I'm just going
to cut right through.
I don't know if
you guys can tell,
but this knife is
so sharp that it's
so easy you don't have to put
a lot of pressure on things.
So if you're putting
a lot of pressure,
you're probably needing
to sharpen your knives.
So I'm just cutting it
into even thickness pieces,
and then I'm going
to cut across.
And then I'll turn it,
and I'll cut across again.
So you can be
exacting or you can
move as quickly as you'd
like depending on how perfect
you want your salad to look.
So that's a large dice.
You can certainly do smaller
for something like this.
So it's closer to the
size of a currant.
And we're good to go.
Little bit smaller here.
Chef's team does
it better, I swear.
Again, this is why I'm
a cook, and not a baker.
So it's just practice.
It's just practice of doing
the same thing over and over.
And it's great to practice on
carrots, and onions, and things
that you have around
the house all the time,
and work on your knife skills.
It's good.
I'm going to add
these julienned ones.
JENNA: The fancy ones.
AMANDA HAAS: And then I'll ad
her fancy, fancy pants ones.
They're gorgeous.
And then the last
trick for radishes.
Now, you can certainly,
certainly do this with a knife.
But can you see how
perfect these are?
I mean they're like
all perfectly even.
I don't know if they
used a mandolin or not.
But this is my one gadget that
I'm obsessed with at work.
And I don't even use
like the fancy mandolins.
You can get some that are
really big with huge disks
that you can change in
and out, which I love.
This is just a
smaller, easier version
of this that has four pads here.
And all I'm going to do, again,
I want a steady surface, right?
And it comes with a guard,
so you can be extra safe.
You can do this a couple ways.
You just slide it right
over, and you're not having
to put a lot of pressure on it.
So I love that.
And then when it gets
down close and you
want to watch your
fingers, just like that.
JENNA: Also you should not look
away while you're doing this.
AMANDA HAAS: I'm like yes.
JENNA: Finger comes right off.
Well, you have the guard.
AMANDA HAAS: Yeah,
but that's one time
where I'll cut corners because
I think it's so much easier.
And I love how consistent it is.
You have to be really
good with a knife
to make them look that
perfect every time.
JENNA: And if you get one
of the small ones, like they
make a lot like this that
are even just with a handle.
You don't have to
wash a big huge one.
I have a big huge one,
it's just so much to wash.
This is easier.
AMANDA HAAS: Yeah,
I agree with you.
And I think that
it's super fast.
And it's a tool I
use all the time.
It's got some shredding
blades for cheese,
or lettuce, or things
like that as well.
So I use that little
tool like crazy.
JENNA: I think they're
indispensable for like gratin.
AMANDA HAAS: Oh, great point.
JENNA: Right, like potatoes.
AMANDA HAAS: Exactly,
makes a huge difference.
I agree with you.
So that's all we're doing
for the salad, you guys.
And it's just really
about mastering
two things, like how
to cook your quinoa
and how to make the vinaigrette.
And then the rest
becomes whatever
you have that you like.
We're going to add some
herbs to it as well.
And put it all together.
So you can see on this
quinoa now too, it's fluffy,
the grain is split, right?
I'm sorry I keep
calling it a grain.
It's a seed, technically.
But that's all you
have to do with it.
The thing I love
about quinoa as well,
Jenna, is that it stays
at room temp really well.
And it lasts in your
fridge really well.
So I started using it like
as a base for stir fries too.
I'll do a savory stir fry.
Looks like this is done as well.
And then it lasts in
your fridge for days.
So something you can think
about making ahead again.
Actually I can have
you do that for me,
while I check the lentils.
Do you want to toss that
with some of the vinaigrette?
And then we'll taste it.
JENNA: [INAUDIBLE] they're
brining it back over there.
AMANDA HAAS: Oh, great.
Fantastic.
So let's take a look at this.
Looks delish.
I don't know if my vegetables
are cooked enough yet.
We're going to taste.
Mm.
I like it when my
food tastes good.
I don't know why I'm always
surprised when it works out,
I'm like, oh, that's
actually tasty.
But it's just such
a joy to cook.
JENNA: Toss it in
this bigger bowl here.
AMANDA HAAS: It needs
five more minutes,
and then it will be done.
The veggies are almost cooked.
But I don't want them to be
so crunchy, you're going,
huh, what's that about?
And then we'll finish both of
these off with fresh herbs.
And herbs, the thing
that's so interesting again
when I really started to
do my research on this,
is that all of these
different ingredients
have different health benefits,
which I find so fascinating.
You know that if you just
grew a garden, and you go out,
and you start pulling
different things, how
they're all different for
you in different ways.
And so mint has great
digestive properties to it,
which we're going to
use in this salad.
We're going to finish the
curry off with cilantro,
and get some great health
benefits from that as well.
Let's put the mint in now.
That's our mint.
Yeah.
We'll mix that in,
and then I'll taste.
How's that?
JENNA: Sounds good.
AMANDA HAAS: Thank you.
It's so fun having
someone do this with me.
I'm not used to it.
JENNA: I'll take it.
AMANDA HAAS: We do our
own dish too at work.
We wash all our dishes.
So if you guys need me to
stay and do dishes, I'm in.
[LAUGHTER]
Mm.
It's crazy to say, but this
has become one of those things
that I actually crave now.
You know it's so clean,
and it's so delicious.
But you have it, and
you feel like you
know you're doing something
good for yourself.
But it's still like, I could
eat a whole bowl of this.
It's kind of crazy.
I'm going to add just a
little bit more oil, and then
a little bit more lemon juice.
Bless you over there.
And let's taste.
See how vibrant it is?
That's the other thing.
I love anything where you
can have this many colors.
And it's just appealing.
You want to try it with me?
Tell me what you think.
JENNA: Of course, I want to try.
AMANDA HAAS: Spoon for you.
JENNA: I thought
you'd never ask.
AMANDA HAAS: Thank you.
What do you think
it needs more of?
JENNA: Maybe a bit more salt.
AMANDA HAAS: Mm-hm.
I agree.
JENNA: That sweetness from
the currants comes through.
It's really delicious.
AMANDA HAAS: You like that?
JENNA: Yeah, it's great.
Right at the end.
AMANDA HAAS: Let's add
a little more salt.
Again, it's so nice when
you can add as you go.
We don't want to overdo it.
JENNA: Yeah, I mean
better to add at the end
than to end up with something
too salty or pungent.
AMANDA HAAS: And salt, many of
you probably already know this,
but salt just brings out all
of the flavors in your food.
So you'll see it in a
lot of desserts as well.
When you're working with
chocolate and vanilla,
it brings out all of
those great notes.
And so it's an amazing
ingredient to use.
Mm.
Delicious.
JENNA: Love it.
AMANDA HAAS: We did a good job.
JENNA: All right,
well, yes, I'll
take some credit,
this much credit.
AMANDA HAAS: So we'll
just finish this off.
And while we're
waiting for this,
does anybody have any
questions about what
we're making here today?
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm going to
start with the breakfast quinoa
[INAUDIBLE] from the book.
AMANDA HAAS: OK, yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: But I'm looking
to create a vegan burger that
would knock people's socks off.
AMANDA HAAS: That
would not be what?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Knock
people's socks off.
Do you have any ideas?
AMANDA HAAS: Do
I have any ideas?
I do.
And a lot of them involve,
it's funny, quinoa, again,
and beets.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Ah.
AMANDA HAAS: I don't
know if you've ever
used beets to create some
sort of a veggie burger.
But I'd be happy to send
you some ideas for it.
We went through
this phase at work
where we were trying to create
the best veggie burger ever.
My boss's husband is vegan.
And he was obsessed with
this one burger he'd had.
So I'd be happy to
send you some ideas.
Beets are great for texture,
and getting like that meatiness.
Mushrooms too, if
you like mushrooms,
can be a great component,
quinoa, oats sometimes.
So I have some ideas.
JENNA: Yeah, you got
to get that umami.
AMANDA HAAS: Recreate it.
Especially vegan without
egg, it's trickier, right?
And so, I'd be happy to help.
I think all of us in the
test kitchen combined
could come up with
something good for you.
Maybe I should do it for my
next book, which is crazy.
JENNA: Do you have an
idea for a next book.
AMANDA HAAS: I think so.
JENNA: Is it super secret?
Can you share?
AMANDA HAAS: No, it's not
secret at all because now I
can bounce it off all of you.
And maybe I should
ask you after you've
tried more of the recipes.
But I was really surprised at
how much this topic resonated
with people because you know
you hear the word inflammation,
and it sounds like, I don't
know, like it's for my mother.
Like it's something
that you deal with when
you're a little bit older.
But when somebody use the
term to describe my health,
I was like, wait a
minute, that's weird.
I was 38 when I started
to figure this out.
And I'm hearing from
people of all ages.
And I'm hearing from people
who have autoimmune issues.
You know so many people come
up to me at my kid's baseball
games, and say, I have
Hashimoto's, or I've
got other thyroid issues,
and I changed my diet,
and I feel so much better.
JENNA: Or chronic pain.
AMANDA HAAS: Chronic, all
these arthritic symptoms.
JENNA: Absolutely.
AMANDA HAAS: So I
think that I want
to keep doing more of this
food, but make people understand
truly that it can be really
easy and approachable.
And these recipes are
all very straightforward.
But maybe put more of like a
weeknight, or like a family
spin on it.
So it's very overtly saying,
you can make this kind
of food every day for everyone.
JENNA: Super easy, you
could do this all the time.
I love it.
AMANDA HAAS: Yeah, so I'd
love your feedback after this,
if you have any ideas.
JENNA: How good is that salad?
AMANDA HAAS: You like?
Even if you don't like quinoa,
you don't have to say yum.
JENNA: It's OK.
AMANDA HAAS: But it's become
my standby, my replacement
for couscous, for sure.
What do you think over here?
You're good?
Oh my gosh, fantastic.
JENNA: You could make it
with a different base.
AMANDA HAAS: Oh,
absolutely you could.
JENNA: Yeah, farrow would
probably be delicious.
AMANDA HAAS: Oh my gosh,
it would be delicious.
JENNA: Yeah.
AMANDA HAAS: Barley,
you could do it
with a lot of different grains.
You certainly don't
have to use quinoa.
JENNA: And you
know, I would argue
you could make a very similar
salad with our salad bar
ingredients here.
We have cold greens.
AMANDA HAAS: Oh
my gosh, amazing.
JENNA: We have quinoa and farro.
AMANDA HAAS: You do?
JENNA: Lots of
those ingredients.
We always have lemon
juice and olive oil.
So you could absolutely
throw this together.
And I think you're going to
start seeing more of this stuff
out and about too, these amazing
grain-based prepared salads.
AMANDA HAAS: I love this place.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm like, I want to eat
lunch here everyday.
I'm telling you, this is
only my second time here,
and I can't believe
how amazing it is.
So that's pretty cool you've
got access to these things
everyday.
And quinoa is a complete
protein, actually.
So when you really do
need to be able to think
for the rest of
the afternoon, it's
a great source of
protein to have around,
and a wonderful option.
JENNA: Yeah, that's
something we've
been talking a lot about
lately is different types
of protein in your diet.
I think the American diet is
very focused on animal protein.
AMANDA HAAS: Yeah.
JENNA: But there's all of these
other great protein bases you
can get in something like this.
So, I think a lot of people
would see this and think,
yeah, I need to put
some chicken on that,
or something on top of it.
AMANDA HAAS: Yeah, right,
something to add to it.
JENNA: But at the
end of the day,
this is a complete protein.
AMANDA HAAS: Yeah.
JENNA: This is a really solid
source for sustained energy.
AMANDA HAAS: Absolutely.
And I think that's my
thing, for the longest
time I didn't feel like I was
having a complete meal unless I
saw shrimp or chicken
or something on that.
Totally great on its own.
Avocado becomes my other
one, just as a standby.
JENNA: Well, that I would want
just because I would want it.
It's terrific.
AMANDA HAAS: So this
is done as well.
And I'm just going to
add a little bit of lime
to it because as I taste it,
I love when you have something
sweet that you add some
acid to it to balance it
out a little bit.
And I just want a
little bit more.
And then I'm going
to have you taste it.
And tell me what you think.
JENNA: Do you do
herb in that as well?
AMANDA HAAS: I'm going
to top it with cilantro.
JENNA: Oh, yum.
AMANDA HAAS: So you
could mix it in.
Again, sometimes when you're
working with lentils and curry,
it's not that beautiful.
No offense to my deliciously
anti-inflammatory recipe here.
But I love finishing things off
with herbs to just balance it.
And one interesting rule
of thumb that you always
learn in cooking school
is that you would never
garnish with something that
you don't want in the recipe,
right?
So if the recipe
has basil and mint,
you wouldn't just throw
parsley on the top.
But I actually want the cilantro
to be part of this recipe,
so I'm going to garnish with
it, and not put any in it.
It can turn kind of dark, if you
put it in, and then let it sit.
And so that's the only reason
I'm not mixing it in directly.
So we're going to just finish
it with a little lime juice.
And then you can tell
me, Jenna, if you
think it needs more
seasoning before we're done.
JENNA: Hovering
excitedly with my spoon.
AMANDA HAAS: I'm going
to give it a splash, just
one little pinch of salt.
And I'll give it a stir.
JENNA: Clearly, everybody was
super into the quinoa salad.
AMANDA HAAS: Or you're
just really hungry.
JENNA: It is.
Well, we do it at lunch,
but we don't tell them
that's why we do it.
[LAUGHTER]
No, it's because it's
delicious of course.
AMANDA HAAS: It's weird though
how these foods can start
to feel really fulfilling.
And I went and cooked at a
magazine recently in New York,
the week my book came out.
And everybody was so cute.
I did a ton of food from it.
But they're like, we still
feel good about ourselves
at the end.
Like you're not
feeling too full,
or like you did something
bad, or that you're so full
you can't think anymore.
JENNA: Yum.
AMANDA HAAS: You like?
JENNA: I like it.
AMANDA HAAS: You think it's OK?
Enough salt, enough acid?
JENNA: Yeah.
AMANDA HAAS: OK,
fantastic, good.
JENNA: I like it a lot.
AMANDA HAAS: So guys
those are two recipes
that are really
basic go-to's for you
that I hope you loved today.
JENNA: How long do you keep the
vinaigrette in the fridge for?
AMANDA HAAS: How long do you
keep the vinaigrettes for?
A really long time.
I think I should probably say
one to two weeks, two to four.
Yeah, a couple of weeks
is fine, absolutely.
If you're putting
things in them that
don't last as well, like
garlic can go a little bit,
I'd keep it at a week.
But vinegar preserves things
really well too, right?
So, yeah, a couple of
weeks, you're good to go.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'
love to ask something,
which is, when we were talking
about throwing the raw egg in,
I'm just curious, do you
think the nature of the egg
is important?
AMANDA HAAS: I could talk to
you about this all day long.
Yes, I do think the nature
of the egg is important.
JENNA: All our eggs
are not created equal.
AMANDA HAAS: They are not.
And it's just like I
think when you start
talking about animal proteins.
A couple people
brought up in my book,
like I can't believe you
would put beef in your book,
this is anti-inflammatory.
Like I had a doctor say that.
But when you start to really
understand animal proteins,
and how important it is to find
out where they're coming from,
and how they're
raised, you realize
that grass-fed beef can work
for you in a really amazing way.
And it's full of
omega-3 and omega-6s,
and has a profile
similar to salmon.
So when you ask about
eggs, it's the same thing.
To joke about "Portlandia," have
you guys ever seen that show?
[INAUDIBLE] chicken,
well, did the chicken
come from down the street?
Well, can I go see
the chicken before you
make the chicken for me?
But I think it is
really important
to know where these
things are coming from.
And so for eggs I look
for organic and pasture.
What's so amazing now is you
can go to the grocery store,
and on most eggs it'll
tell you how it's
been raised, which is amazing.
JENNA: Cage-free, yup.
AMANDA HAAS: It's going to
change the flavor of it.
And it's definitely going
to change the health
properties of it as well.
Yeah, great question.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
so I've been interested
in I guess diets, for
lack of a better word,
that health issues
for a while, primarily
on the digestive side.
So I've tried gluten
free, to paleo,
to then the latest that
I've kind of resonated
with the most, but is the
most difficult, is low FODMAP.
So I don't know if you are
familiar with that at all,
but, like, for example, the
worst offenders are gluten.
So that's fine, but
also garlic and onion.
AMANDA HAAS: Exactly.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Which makes it
a really difficult experience.
AMANDA HAAS: Tell me
again, you said low FODMAP?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
AMANDA HAAS: It's so funny.
I just had a girlfriend
bring this up to me.
What's your name?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Lucy.
AMANDA HAAS: Lucy
has been trying
to work on some diets that
help digestive problems, which
is something I get
into in the book
as well, kind of about what's
going on with our guts.
You hear a lot these
days about a leaky gut,
or digestive issues
around certain foods.
So trying gluten free, and
paleo, and then the FODMAPS
diet, which is
definitely different.
And there are some foods that
make it much worse than others.
I think it's
fascinating, and I just
started to read up on it
probably about a year ago.
I had a girlfriend say she
had huge success with it.
And so I think it
speaks to the fact
that we are all
different, right?
And so I can share
the story of for me,
I realized right
away that gluten
was one of the big ones for me.
And then dairy was a
secondary one for me.
But it's a matter
of figuring out
what's affecting you
positively and negatively,
and going from there.
So I always encourage
people to try
things to feel better that way.
And it's hard to eliminate
foods from your diet,
and then try to work them
back in to see what happens.
But we're all unique.
And so you might
find that that is
the way you need to eat
for the rest of your life,
and that you feel
amazing that way.
I will say, just
speaking from someone
who was told they couldn't have
anything, how easy it was when
I realized that gluten was what
was making me feel terrible.
People are like,
don't you miss it?
Yeah, I miss great
pizza, of course.
But I feel so much
better that it doesn't
feel like a sacrifice anymore.
So that's my only positive
spin on it for you,
is that if you find
out that it's honestly
one of these things that we
are used to eating a ton of,
you'll be OK, and you'll
feel so much better.
JENNA: And it could be
something innocuous.
I have a friend who's son,
it's artificial coloring.
AMANDA HAAS: Oh my gosh.
So funny, huge.
JENNA: Insane, like
one stick of gum,
and he's completely off
the rails for a whole day.
AMANDA HAAS: Right.
JENNA: And I was asking
her, how did you even
figure out that was the thing?
AMANDA HAAS: That was it?
JENNA: And it was a similar
process with doctors.
But I noticed it's
on your list as well.
AMANDA HAAS: It's on my list.
JENNA: Yeah, it could be
something so innocuous
that you would never think of.
But until she started trying.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And dyes
are in your medication too.
AMANDA HAAS: They are.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I recently
was prescribed medication,
and I said, I can't take that.
I took it Friday night and
went out until Sunday noon.
And they said, oh, because
it has this dye in it.
I said, well, I'd like
the version without.
AMANDA HAAS: It doesn't exist.
That happened to my
dad like 30 years ago.
And he's a doctor.
He has asthma.
He's like, I'm having an
allergic reaction to the asthma
medication you're
giving me with food dye.
But food coloring's
on that list.
And I think it
goes back to again,
it was really frustrating for
me to realize that it took me
20 years to realize that, if
it doesn't come from the ground
naturally, it's probably
not that good for us.
And so that's a great example
of one as well that many of us
are sensitive to.
JENNA: Yeah, and I hope that
awareness to that type of thing
will push change
because really, why
does a medication need to
be dyed a particular color?
AMANDA HAAS: Purple.
JENNA: It's totally arbitrary.
AMANDA HAAS: Right.
JENNA: Yeah, so we can tell
all of the medications we
take apart from one another?
It's indicative of
maybe other problems.
AMANDA HAAS: Right, yeah, it is.
JENNA: Well, thank you
so much, everybody.
AMANDA HAAS: Oh, it's such
a treat to be here today.
Thank you.
JENNA: Thanks for spending
some time with us.